salut c'est eric judor pour brut vous
voulez être drôle suivez mes conseils
sur 700 points numéro 1
l'humour absurde démarrer une phrase de
la manière la plus raisonnable est
normale possible et terminer par le mot
merguez c'est sans doute le le genre
d'humour qui je pense vieillit le mieux
au monde parce que le mot merguez sera
toujours drôle qu'on le dise aujourd'hui
ou dans 30 ans contient pas de de
référence à notre à notre actualitté ça
vieillit très très bien
or on peut en rire à nouveau dans dix
ans les marx brothers par exemple sont
un cas d'école d'humour absurde
ils font n'importe quoi c'est totalement
absurde plus burlesques ça sera notre
point numéro 2 mais on peut en rire
encore aujourd'hui numéro deux du lourd
burlesque humour burlesque est ce que
c'est c'est faire rire avec le corps
c'est ce casser la gueule faire des
micro chute comme celle ci mais en mieux
avec un bruit de casseroles qui tombait
une sortie de champ par exemple un mec
qui se prendra une porte dans la gueule
qu'on voit dans la rue qui ouvre une
porte ou que cela prend qui se casse la
gueule en remontant au montant trottoir
ça nous fait invariablement rire et
c'est un humour qui vieillit aussi très
très bien en numéro 3
je passerai à au jeu de mots le jeu de
mots le jeu de mots jouer avec la langue
peu importe alors que tu pratiques ça dd
ça déclenche le rire parce que le rire
est déclenchée par la surprise
l'inattendu et si soudain on place un
mot à un endroit où il ne devrait pas
être ou alors où il a un double sens ça
devient drôle exemple [ __ ] merde j'en
ai pas pourtant j'étais le roi du jeu de
mots à une époque
ah si j'en ai fait une mais pas avec
votre site brut
c'est avec combiné
et je leur ai demandé est ce que vous
faites toujours des comédies musicales
pas ouf pas ou feint c'est pour combiner
donc on s'en fout mais je leur ai donné
gratos mais voilà donc c'est un exemple
qui raconte aussi que le jeu de mots
c'est un peu claqué comme humour c'est
un peu vieillot donc méfie toi si tu
veux utiliser un humour qui vieillit
bien n'utilise pas le jeu de mots doux
alors nous passons donc à une 4ème
catégorie un quatrième genre qui est le
genre qui est très moderne aujourd'hui
le malaise créé une vanne la rater et
laisser un temps derrière comme je lé
fais juste juste avant avec un mini
musicale vous voyez ce train et kia
c'est ce que la belle tour moderne c'est
faire de la merde et derrière l'assumer
et laisser le temps jane s'installer
jusqu'à déclencher le rire et se rire et
provoqué invariablement parce qu on est
gêné pour l'autre et donc ça interrompt
ce moment jane sade sam dégonfler la
baudruche
le comique de répétition qu'est ce que
c'est numéro deux du c'est ce que je
viens de faire
en énumérant sans arrêt numéro 3 des
numéros avec un bruit et toujours cette
même musique qui revient et au bout d'un
moment toujours un petit peu pour la
gêne aussi que ça provoque numéro 4 on
se sent obligé de rire j'y ai rajouté le
petit temps à la fin pour être drôle je
reprendrai un débat de 2,2 des gens que
j'admire
ricky gervais et larry david qui
discutaient du mot entre eux et qu'ils
considéraient qu on ne peut pas être au
sommet de son art comics avant 50 ans
parce que on accumule de l'expérience on
accumule de la culture et donc des
références et avec tout ça on a un gros
pot dans lequel on mélange plein d'idées
et on peut faire plein de contrepèteries
plein de gags absurdes et plein de
cascades rigolote
et donc il ya une certaine forme de
maturité à avoir en comédie après il ya
des gens absolument géniaux
immédiatement je cite au hasard jamel
debbouze qui dès 18 ans et a pété de
rire comme jeu dans platane je décline
vraiment la gêne comme un argument ou
une candidat un levier comique très fort
je vais terminer par sa merci attend
maintenant